[موسيقى]
موجز الاخبار من الجزيره السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله قال وزرو الدفاع الامريكي
الطائرات المقاتله تمكنت من اسقاط المنطار
الصيني قباله سواحل ولايه كارولاينا
الجنوبيه واكد ان عمليه في مياه البحر
لانتشال حطام بالمنطاد تجري حاليا واضافنا
المنطقه استعمل من قبل الصين في محاوله
لمراقبه مواقع استراتيجيه
وكان مدير مكتبي لهجته شؤون الخارجيه
الصيني وانجي قال انه يتعين على بلاده
والولايات المتحده الحفاظ على تركيزهما
والتواصل في الوقت المناسب واضافها في
اتصال مع وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
ان على البلدين تجنب سوي التقدير
اعلنت الولايات المتحده تقديم مساعده
عسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا بمليارين و200
مليون دولار امريكي تضم منظومات الدفاع
الجوي وقال الفينتاجون ان المساعدات
الجديده تشمل صواريخها المضاده للدبابات
وصواريخها خاصه براجمات هايمارس ومعدات
عسكريه اخرى
من جهته قال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
ديمتري
اوكرانيا بمزيد من الاسلحه الامريكيه
سيزيد العمليات الانتقاميه الروسيه وتوعد
بان الرد الروسيه سيكون سريعا وقاسيا اذا
تعرضت شبه جزيره القرم وعمق الاراضي
الروسيه للقصف واعقل ان روسيا مستعده
لاستخدام جميع انواع الاسلحه بما في ذلك
النوويه
بينما قال مستشار رئاسه الاوكرانيه ان
القانون الدوليه يجيز لاوكرانيا ان تحرر
اراضيها باستخدام اي اداه وان شبه جزيره
القرم ارض اوكرانيه
في الاثناء اعلنا الجيش الاوكراني عن صفقه
تبادل جديده وصفها بالكبيره بينه وبين
الجيش الروسي اطلق بموجبها سراحه 116
جنديا اوكرانيا كما استعاد ثلاثه جثث
لمتطوعين اجانب في صفوف القوات الاوكرانيه
اتهمت كل من الولايات المتحده وفرنسا
وبريطانيا والمانيا الحكومه الايرانيه
بعدم الوفاء بالتزاماتها بموجب اتفاقيه
حظر انتشار الاسلحه النوويه و 10 بيان
رباعي مشترك الى ان تقرير الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه افاد بان الطيران عدلت سرا
منشاه فورد ينتاج اليورانيوم على التعاليا
في المقابل قالها كبير المفاوضين
الايرانيين علي باقرين طهران التزمت
بتعهداتها الوارده في الاتفاق النووي
وبانها تتوقع وان تتعامل الاطراف الاخرى
بالطريقه نفسها وكان رئيس منظمه الطاقه
الذريه الايرانيه محمد اسلامي قد قلينا
المواقف السياسيه التي تتبناها الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه بشان بلاده نتيجه
عن ضغوط من خارج الوكاله
اين كنت انطبق اوقاتكم بكل خير